rising out of the tuscan hills are some
colorful and unusual figures
inspired by tarot cards
[Music]
the tarot park is located in tuscany a
few hours outside of rome
the park took 20 years to complete and
includes 22 figures from the tarot deck
there's a sphinx that leads to a golden
skeleton riding a blue horse over a
green sea
this represents death
the hanged man can be found inside one
of the sparkling grottoes suspended from
the ceiling
and one of the most bizarre figures is
the oracle which is a hollow-eyed figure
surrounded and covered by snakes
the eccentric artist who created this
garden was nikki d
in the early 1950s mickey was committed
to an asylum and believes it was art
that eventually healed her
she wanted to create a place that would
have the same healing effect on those
who visited
the park opened in 1998 just four years
before nicki's death
in her own words she dreamt of building
a garden that would be a dialogue
between sculpture and nature
a place to dream in
[Music]
you